und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka guten
abend eigentlich sollte die
weltklimakonferenz in madrid gestern zu
ende gehen doch es wird immer noch
verhandelt und es könnte sogar sein dass
die ganze veranstaltung kraftakt hat es
stehen sich antreiber und bremser
gegenüber zu den bremsern gehören neben
saudi arabien und brasilien auch die usa
wobei es durchaus interessant ist wie
kraftvoll die amerikaner mit verhandeln
dabei sind sie eigentlich aus dem klima
abkommen ausgestiegen doch da es auch
für so etwas förmliche kündigungsfristen
gibt sind sie offiziell noch bis
november nächsten jahres mitglied ein
sehr aktives mitglied wie sich jetzt in
madrid zeigt von dort berichtet volker
angres da können wir uns doch gleich
aufhängen meinen umweltaktivisten zum
verlauf der konferenz zumal nicht nur
ihnen die zeit dahin schmilzt warten auf
das abschlussplenum sechs mal verschoben
nun soll es um 1 uhr losgehen die
dokumente die bisher auf dem tisch
liegen bringen klimaschützer in rage
betracht die textentwürfe der konferenz
präsidentschaft sind desaströse absolut
erschreckend
dieser text betrügt einen menschen auf
dem planeten das ist völlig inakzeptabel
sein denn dann ist komplett leer
auch die deutsche delegation zwischen
enttäuschung und entsetzen in den
abschluss texten fehlen unter anderem
eine bestätigung für mehr klimaschutz ab
2020 zu sorgen
eine zustimmung die wissenschaftliche
arbeit des weltklimarats anzuerkennen
und transparente regeln für einen handel
mit emissionszertifikaten
es ist die weltklimakonferenz wir haben
in europa jetzt gerade den jugendlichen
deal auf den weg gebracht da kann doch
so eine konferenz nicht ohne ergebnis
bleiben hier sind ganz viele die
verstanden haben was die wissenschaft
und sagt die wissen dass man was tun
muss
lieber protest was seit monaten rund um
die welt vor allem junge menschen bewegt
angst um ihre zukunft das hat sich
offenbar nicht auf die konferenz
ausgewirkt dabei findet klimaschutz
durchaus stadt ganz ohne konferenz in
vielen partnerländern die
bundesregierung unterstützt derzeit über
700 projekte mit über 3,5 milliarden
das ziel ist den entwicklungsländern zu
ermöglichen direkt den sprung zur
kohlenstoffarme wirtschaft mit
erneuerbarer energie zum beispiel zu
schaffen
beispiel marokko das solare wärme
kraftwerke nur mit deutschem knowhow und
deutscher kofinanzierung gebaut
produziert das kraftwerk öko strom für
rund eine million menschen
beispiel indien die hälfte des globalen
emissionen zuwachses der letzten fünf
jahre fand hier statt eine deutsch
indische partnerschaft setzt sich für
mehr solarkraftwerke 1
mit dem strom soll noch immer mehr
elektroautos unterwegs sein
beispiele die nahelegen dass sich die
kommenden un klimakonferenzen neu
ausrichten müssen
das bedeutet zum beispiel für den
nächsten klimagipfel in glasgow das
vermutlich der finanzsektor eine
zentrale rolle spielen wird wie muss er
gestaltet werden welche rahmensetzung
muss er bekommen damit er die paris
ziele unterstützt finanzminister aus 53
ländern waren in madrid schon vertreten
zum ersten mal überhaupt auf einer
un-klimakonferenz wenigstens das ein
gutes zeichen
volker angres beobachtet das für uns in
madrid wie ist denn jetzt der letzte
stand woran hakt es
zunächst einmal ist es so dass offenbar
die dokumente überarbeitet werden also
ein totales scheitern zeichnet sich im
moment nicht ab das kann aber noch
dauern wir haben gehört dass demnächst
nochmal beratungen stattfinden zu den
strittigen punkten wandern tatsächlich
das abschlussplenum stattfindet ein uhr
war ja angekündigt das wissen wir nicht
und welche qualität die texte haben
werden das ist auch noch nicht absehbar
aber sie meinen irgend ein gemeinsames
kommuniqué wird es geben also kein
komplettes scheitern je nachdem wie man
das dann bewerten will das ist eine
reine vermutung rein theoretisch kann es
auch noch komplett scheitern denn bei
den un konferenzen muss am ende des
tages einstimmig abgestimmt werden also
es reicht eine einzige gegenstimme eines
landes und dann würde entweder noch mal
in die arbeitsgruppen verwiesen oder
dann ist tatsächlich die konferenz
gescheitert der druck kommt daher dass
viele länder jetzt merken dass schluss
ist mit der klimaschutz kosmetik was
bisher so der fall war
jetzt heißt es ran an den umbau der
nationalen volkswirtschaften eben
umstellung auf regenerative energien
eben alles tun um klimaschutz umzusetzen
und da haben sehr sehr viele länder
immer noch große probleme
die beispiele haben wir ja gesehen
brasilien gehört dazu argentinien gehört
dazu die usa auch wenn sie formal
demnächst aussteigen werden noch können
sie wie du in der anmoderation gesagt
hast noch kräftig mitfahrenden was sie
auch tun
dankeschön vollgas nach madrid wie stark
der klimawandel deutschland jetzt schon
trifft und wie wissenschaftler die
gegenmaßnahmen der politik bewerten
das können sie auch im netz nachlesen
bei uns auf heute.de
sehr geehrter herr kollege lieber olaf
so beginnt der brief von
wirtschaftsminister peter altmaier an
finanzminister olaf scholz
es geht um die einführung der kassenbon
pflicht ab ersten januar dann sollen
nämlich auch cafés kioske bäckereien
oder metzger dazu verpflichtet werden
dem kunden für jeden einkauf einen beleg
auszustellen vorausgesetzt sie nutzen
elektronische kassen
damit wird es für händler oder
gastronomen deutlich schwerer schwarz zu
kassieren
der finanzminister erwartet üppige
zusatzeinnahmen
der einzelhandel hat jedoch nach allen
kräften versucht diese neuregelung zu
verhindern und jetzt kurz vor
ladenschluss sozusagen haben die
verbände im wirtschaftsminister einen
mitstreiter gefunden ganzen team
berichtet ob im dönerladen in der
eisdiele oder beim bäcker auch bei
kleinen einkäufen soll es ab januar
einen kassenbeleg geben
der grund am ladentisch wird der staat
um milliarden betrogen manipulierte
kassen tricksereien bei der
mehrwertsteuer der pflicht bon sol
künftig einen nachweis über jedes
geldgeschäft liefern
auch wenn es den kunden nervt total
überflüssig ich habe kein interesse
wirtschaftsminister altmaier stellt sich
in einem brief jetzt gegen die neue
kassenzettel pflicht und damit gegen den
finanzminister lieber ola schreibt er
dies wird zu einem mehraufwand an
bürokratie führen und im gesamten handel
werden milliarden zusätzlicher bors
gedruckt und in den allermeisten fällen
direkte müll landen auch aus
nachhaltigkeits gründen sollte dieser
abfall vermieden werden mit freundlichen
grüßen dein peter wir kämpfen an vielen
stellen gegen bürokratie und deshalb
müssen wir sehr vorsichtig sein wenn wir
regelungen machen die man niemandem
erklären kann über die sich viele
mittelständler erregen und die von den
bürgern auch nicht nachvollzogen werden
altmaiers vorstoß begeistert den
einzelhandelsverband
manipulationssichere kassen ab september
2020 auf pflicht würden doch reichen die
bons pflicht sei unnötig belasten
das ist keine frage der großen koalition
sondern eigentlich mehr eine frage des
gesunden menschenverstand ist natürlich
sehr steuerbetrug nicht okay dagegen
muss man dem vorgehen der kassenbon und
die pflicht den kassenbon geben kunden
zu geben auch wenn sie im brötchen oder
eine zahnpasta kaufen wird aber im ziel
nicht besser helfen
vom spd finanzminister heute keine
stellungnahme
dafür zeigt sich die spd fraktion
irritiert über altmaiers lastminute
brandbrief ich bin ehrlich was er
einsetzt dass man zwei wochen bevor es
in kraft tritt mit seinem vorschlag
kommt oma drei jahre zeit hat sich
vorzubereiten
das läuft jetzt auch klug überlegt hat
ihr eine breite mehrheit im bundestag
und im bundesrat dafür gegeben und es
wird zeit dass dieses gesetz kommt noch
gut zwei wochen bleiben peter altmaier
für eine änderung auf den letzten
drücker
ab dem ersten januar 2020 greift sonst
die bom flicht 15 macht weiterhin die
nachrichten
bundeskanzlerin merkel hat vor dem
gipfel zum fachkräfte
einwanderungsgesetz am montag im
kanzleramt betont
wie wichtig es für deutschland sei
ausreichend fachkräfte zu haben
merkel sagte in ihrem wöchentlichen
video-podcast neben einer guten
ausbildung für die menschen hierzulande
müsse man sich auch um fachkräfte aus
der eu und auch von außerhalb der
europäischen union bemühen wie das am
besten zu realisieren ist darüber soll
dann am montag bei dem gipfel mit
ländern wirtschaft und gewerkschaften
beraten werden
die erst vor rund vier wochen in italien
entstand eine sogenannte sardinen
bewegung hat heute in rom zehntausende
mobilisiert zu einer großdemonstration
gegen rechtspopulismus
viele der demonstranten trugen bilder
und figuren von sardinen denn ihr ziel
ist es so viele menschen auf die straße
zu bringen dass sie eng gedrängt stehen
wie sardinen
entstanden ist die bewegung aus einer
protestaktion gegen die rechte leger und
ihren chef ex-innenminister salvini der
rumänische staatspräsident klaus
johannis wird mit dem aachener
karlspreis 2020 ausgezeichnet er habe
mit großem einsatz und erfolg rumänien
zu einer pro-europäischen
rechtsstaatlichen politik geführt und er
sei ein wichtiger mittler und
brückenbauer zwischen west- und
osteuropäischen gesellschaften ist es in
der begründung des
karlspreisdirektoriums der aachener
karlspreis wird seit 1950 für besondere
verdienste um die europäische einigung
verliehen
der schauspieler gerd baltus ist tot er
starb gestern im alter von 87 jahren in
hamburg bald galt zeitweise als der
meistbeschäftigte deutsche fernseh
schauspieler bekannt wurde er vor allem
durch seine rollen in krimiserien die
der rag tatort oder der alte und jetzt
die lottozahlen dieses samstags sie
lauten die immer ohne gewähr
4 16 20 31 34 38 superzahl 8 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 55 6
vielerorts in deutschland war heute ein
tag mit viel wind beziehungsweise ist es
immer noch und für teile von bayern
gelten aktuell unwetter warnungen vor
orkanartigen böen und die aussichten für
morgen sind so im norden und in
alpennähe nur vereinzelt schauer sonst
stark bewölkt und häufig regel bei 7 bis
13 grad
dazu bläst ein stürmischer wind um west
die weiteren aussichten es fällt kaum
noch reden
der wind lässt nach und es wird sehr
mild am dienstag örtlich bis 15 grad
beide großen kirchen die evangelische
wie katholische haben sich beim thema
seenotrettung von flüchtlingen eindeutig
positioniert sie stehen hinter diesen
missionen als selbstverständlichen akt
christliche nächsten und sie belassen es
auch nicht bei moralischer unterstützung
sondern helfen mit spenden und die
evangelische kirche hat sogar einen
verein gegründet mit dem ein eigenes
schiff finanziert werden soll
in münchen gab es heute einen
ökumenischen gottesdienst der daran
erinnert wie viele menschen bereits im
mittelmeer ertrunken sind
brigitte sauer berichtet filimon stammt
aus eritrea 2014 kam er als
bootsflüchtlinge nach europa heute liest
er im münchner dom die namen von
menschen vor die die flucht über das
mittelmeer nicht überlebt haben
14 jahre war er alt als er von libyen
aus die riskante überfahrt in einem
schlepper bot gewagt hat er sah für sich
keinen anderen ausweg
dann will ich in libyen bleiben liebe es
gefährlich die menschen werden getötet
vergewaltigt meistens frauen statt
in lübesse leiden besser mit reagieren
wenn ihr es senkt das boot dann dein
leben zu ende
der oberste protestantin deutschland
heinrich bedford strohm und der oberste
katholik in deutschland reinhard marx
fordern mehr solidarität mit den
bootsflüchtlingen denn allein in diesem
jahr sind bislang mindestens 1200
menschen auf dem mittelmeer umgekommen
die staatliche seenotrettung ist
eingestellt wurden ersatzlos eingestellt
worden
es kann nicht sein dass wir einfach
zuschauen wie die menschen ertrinken
das an eine grenze
das vom christentum geprägten europa
menschen umkommen also das darf nicht
sein dass nämlich ein skandal
seenotretter halten vor dem münchner dom
eine mahnwache mit dabei kapitän reich
aus dem bayerischen landsberg
noch im september hatte er mit einem
ehemaligen fischkutter mehr als hundert
flüchtlinge aus seenot gerettet und nach
italien gebracht sein schiff wurde
beschlagnahmt er hätte die geretteten an
die libysche küstenwache übergeben
müssen argumentieren die italienischen
behörden
es ist auch um entspricht diese menschen
in diese folterlager zurückzuführen weil
ich habe leute auf dem schiff die kann
so große angst davor dort wieder
hinzukommen dass sie lieber ins meer
springen und tod sind als dorthin zurück
zu müssen
auch fünf jahre nach seiner flucht lässt
filimon das erlebte nicht los gerade
schreibt er darüber ein buch träumt
davon einen film zu drehen über die
gefährliche flüchtlings route ich will
die menschen erklären warum wir kommen
durch die gefährliche länder nach europa
warum wir riskieren durch die sodann und
die wüste und ich die libyen mittelmeer
es ist sehr wichtig für mich also das
ist das zu machen so wie er stellen auch
die kirchen in deutschland heute die
frage wie viel menschlichkeit europa für
bootsflüchtlinge aufbringen kann und
will
eine antwort wird es so schnell nicht
geben noch ein nachtrag zu den
nachrichten vorher war in der meldung
über den aachener karlspreis
un-generalsekretär antonio guterres
eingeblendet der hat den preis auch
schon bekommen aber in diesem fall ging
es um den aachener karlspreis 2020 für
klaus johannis das was von uns und
weiter geht's gleich mit dem aktuellen
sportstudio und danach so ging nur 25
melden sich die kollegen von heute
express morgan auf wiedersehen
[Musik]